so you're doing research on sort of a
holiday-themed film or maybe it's
because you also like holidays themed
films I mean talked about a Christmas
story and things like that what makes a
good either Christmas film or Halle even
Halloween something that's a theme that
they know every year it's going to come
up people are gonna want to watch it
they're gonna want to watch it in
certain environment they're gonna be in
a certain place in their lives whether
on vacation or having time off from work
well when I decided to write a Christmas
movie for this low-budget Christmas
movie I looked at my favorite Christmas
news that I liked elf a Christmas story
even Bad Santa and it moves like that
and I analyzed them I mean you know it's
my business my job so I analyze them I
see what do they have in common what
makes it a Christmas movie and why do I
like it and I discovered some things in
common with the good Christmas movies
first of all Christmas has to be in
jeopardy Christmas must be in danger in
elf literally Santa can't fly his sleigh
until people believe in Christmas again
yay in a Christmas story if he doesn't
get that BB gun okay his Christmas will
be ruined or hi all the great Christmas
movies Christmas is in jeopardy and the
other thing is it has to be family has
to be about family Christmas is about
reaffirming the family unit in National
imprudence of Christmas vacation okay
his relatives visit in the form of Randy
Quaid who's obnoxious Chevy Chase can't
stand him okay
he's not getting Chevy Chase doesn't get
the Christmas bonus that he thought he
deserves and that he needs you know to
keep his family together and so there's
all this dangerous stuff his relatives
are ruining Christmas his boss is
ruining Christmas and all he wants to do
is have a great Christmas okay so that's
in danger too and it's the family that
provides the solution when he finds out
that he's not getting the Christmas
bonus for his boss his crazy brother
Randy Quaid kidnaps the boss and brings
him there
so that Chevy Chase can tell him off
okay which is a stupid thing to do to
kidnap your boss but the boss has an
epiphany you know and it says and then
comes through and gives us so it's it
gives the bonus so his crazy stupid
weird family that Chevy just just hated
has provided the means to save Christmas
okay so that's another element that's in
that one in elf
okay the piece of the there to literally
find his family he finds his father who
James Caan who doesn't believe in
Christmas okay but by the end of the
movie James Caan has reaffirmed that he
is indeed his son that Will Ferrell is
his son and now he believes in Christmas
so it's in every single good Christmas
movie Christmas is in danger it involves
the family and together they save
Christmas
and weirdly enough I mean if you have
are enough of a writer geeky audience
they'd appreciate this but in every
Christmas movie to almost all of them
there's a subtle and and brief sexual
element which sounds crazy but think
about it and it's a Wonderful Life
there's this fallen woman which in the
parlance of the time meant you know a
trampled this way and she's gonna leave
town so there's that brief thing about
that it's like why are they put why did
they put this in here in a Christmas
story there's the leg lamp okay which
was very sexual it's a damned leg this
big you know and like with that black
stocking on it and the wife is like uh
what's that doing here she's threatened
sexually and in the Chevy Chase movie a
Christmas vacation he's looking at the
neighbor over the fist the woman who's
swimming in the bikini and there's a
slow-motion shot and she's swimming and
the waters dripping off of her and what
is this doing what is this
the fantasy doing in a Christmas movie
in elf
she's taking his zooey deschanel is
taking a shower where she's in the
shower
she's naked in the shower we don't see
it but we can tell and she's singing and
Buddy the elf is listening and he's in
there he's not looking but he's
listening so that also is like a sexual
romantic element what are these little
things doing in these Christmas movies
when I was analyzing I thought why are
these here why do they work and then it
hit me it's there because Christmas
itself the holiday season has kind of
nobility about it as sort of a higher
purpose people are and people are being
their best selves they're giving they're
buying things for people they're getting
together by the fire they're snuggling
up there's all these really wonderful
positive knowable things that are people
doing these higher things okay and when
they bring in this sexual element no
matter how silly it is it was in the
shower if it's the leg it's earthy that
is a little touch of earthiness you know
of something based something a little
core something very primal down here
where's the other thing hits you in the
heart this hits you in the gut you know
and and it's just there I decided it's
just there to provide contrast to the
nobility of the rest of the movie okay
and it's gives the sentimentality of a
bigger impact in the end and I thought
about I thought you know what if they
didn't have little coarse elements in
there the film would be treacle you know
it would stick to the bottom of your
shoe it would just be too sickly sweet
and by doing that you have the
perspective by diverting a little bit
into the earthly area you then give
yourself the viewer gives themselves
permission to enjoy the sentimentality
and the sweetness at the end that's my
theory anyway
you